bonnet bonjour vous êtes sur place
quelle est la situation au devant le
tribunal mais bonjour sa lente vous
l'entendez peut-être derrière moi les
avocats sont en colère et ils bloquent
l'entrée du palais du sis ont regardé
depuis près de huit heures 30 du matin
dans une le tout dans une bonne ambiance
avec beaucoup de champ ils
l'interpellent là mais la garde des
sceaux beaucoup de personnes sont
également juste devant prennent des
photos beaucoup d'avocats distribuent du
café et des croissants aux personnes qui
sont censés rentrer à l'intérieur non
plus tous ceux dans une ambiance
globalement plutôt bonne enfant à des
avocats qui manifestent depuis des
semaines contre la réforme des retraites
je suis justement avec anne-sophie les
veinards membre du conseil de l'ordre
bonjour merci d'être avec nous on
l'entend depuis depuis tout à l'heure
vos collègues qui se mobilisent et cela
depuis des semaines est ce que vous êtes
plutôt positives pour l'avenir
je ne suis pas très positif pour
l'avenir parce que j'ai la sensation
actuellement que nous ne sommes pas du
tout entendu et même que nous sommes
méprisés par le gouvernement qui
n'écoute pas à ce que l'on essaye de
porter comme message depuis le 6 janvier
dernier
justement la garde des sceaux avait dit
regretter cette cette mobilisation est
ce que vous avez le sentiment que depuis
il ya eu une porte ouverte vers les
avocats ge
pour l'instant nous n'avons aucune porte
ouverte et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous restons en grève totale depuis le 6
janvier puisque n'avons aucune
perspective d'évolution et de quelque
chose qui pourrait être satisfaisant
aujourd'hui cette réforme des retraites
commence qu'elle vous
handicap alors c'est très simple pour
les cabinets
les petits petit c'est à dire les
cabinets qui acceptent l'aide
juridictionnelle et donc la défense des
justiciables les plus modestes
nous allons voir nos cotisations doublée
et donc nous allons devoir fermer ou
alors cessé de prendre les dossiers des
personnes les plus modestes parce que
nous n'aurons plus la capacité
financière de les accepter
c'est ça l'enjeu aujourd'hui et c'est
pour ça aussi que nous avons
complètement arrêté de travailler depuis
le 6 janvier parce que l'impact direct
ce serait aussi sur les justiciables et
sur l'accès aux droits mais aussi les
conditions de travail qui se dégradent
j'ai pu parler avec quelques avocats qui
me disait que plus les années passent et
plus le métier donné de plus en plus
difficile le métier devient de plus en
plus difficile mais en fait ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que c'est tout
l'appareil judiciaire qui se dégrade
c'est à dire que les avocats sont
impactés les greffiers sont impactés les
magistrats sont impactés c'est toute la
justice finalement qu' un petit peu la
laisser pour compte et qui manquent de
moyens avec des professionnels qui sont
en fait à bout de souffle
justement si nombre de mois
depuis des années est ce que ça te
réformer les retraites c'est un petit
peu la goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder
le vase c'est exactement ça ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est qu'il ya déjà eu
une grosse mobilisation contre le projet
loi justice il ya environ un an
nous sommes tous en train de devoir nous
adapter à cette réforme qui est passé
dans la précipitation et aujourd'hui on
nous propose encore autre chose qui va
pour le coup carrément de bouleverser
l'accès au droit
parce que les avocats vont continuer à
se mobiliser même si plusieurs d'avocats
dont vous me dites que
vous n'êtes pas forcément entendus par
le gouvernement nous allons continuer à
nous mobiliser nous allons continuer à
porter nos messages nous on porte la
robe tous les jours où on défend les
gens tous les jours normalement dans les
périodes habituelles et nous ce que l'on
souhaite c'est défendre notre profession
dans ce cas là le plus beau c'est à dire
défendre les plus démunis
merci beaucoup à vous pour ce témoignage
vous l'avez entendu samantha des avocats
qui restent mobilisés et vidéos
continuer à bloquer d'autres tribunaux à
défiler dans les rues de paris une grève
qui a été reconduit d'ailleurs jusqu'au
3 mars
merci beaucoup monnaie à bout de l or
dans toutes ces précisions en direct du
tribunal de nanterre merci à vous